Chris Christie Chris Christie has just
visited Ukraine he's visited Ukraine and
he's done so on a mission to bring
Ukraine President Vladimir zielinski
some Bon Jovi memorabilia John wrote out
the lyrics uh to the song It's My Life
which serves as an inspiration for a lot
of the citizens in in Odessa as they
were preparing for the invasion by the
Russians he wrote it out in his own
hands got it framed and I brought it to
president zielinski presented to him and
said that this is representative of many
of the American people and what they
feel about the cause that's being fought
for in Ukraine look I like Bon Jovi but
you know
this is just not this doesn't seem like
a good a good use of War resources and
it would seem to undercut the argument
that we need to keep sending 10
bazillion dollars over to Ukraine
because it's on the brink of collapse
and we're going to head into World War
III a lot of Tourism for a war zone